[Music]
all right has now been officially 328
days since the special council Robert
Muller was appointed to investigate
so-called Russian interference into our
elections all right tonight we're still
asking the question where is any
evidence of collusion show us nothing so
far
not a whiff nothing no evidence now
instead of concrete facts information
surrounding Russia's the illicit actions
we now have in this country what is a
runaway investigation it's spinning out
of control it's led by Muller and his
merry band of trump hating deep state
sycophants that's just a fact now we
have gone from the prosecution of Paul
Manafort over years old payments from
Ukraine not Russia to now an
investigation into alleged Affairs
between Trump and a porn star named
stormy Daniels you can't make this up
and now today we're learning from
reports that FBI agents during the Kohn
raid they're actually looking for
information about payments made to a
former Playboy Playmate Karen McDougal
does anyone actually believe that a porn
star and a former Playboy Playmate that
they're gonna shed any light on
potential collusion with Russia the
answer is of course not Robert Muller is
now officially gone rogue and declared
war against the president and big news
tonight according to reports stormy
Daniels CNN will be so proud they are
now cooperating with Robert Muller and
his probe and of course this rogue
activity from Muller it's nothing new
remember back in March former Trump
political adviser Sam Nunn Berg he said
Muller was seeking information regarding
Michael cones payments yep you got it
too stormy Daniels so much for Russian
interference did Miller's folks ask
anything that related to these issues
around payments to people or women well
look they asked if I had ever heard
anything about that and my answer is I
never have I don't know anything about
it and I wanted have known II don't want
all right so sadly tonight what's
happening is Muller's runaway train of
an investigation it's something we have
now been warning you about for over a
year I've told you there are five forces
actively working against Donald Trump
they have from the beginning it is your
corrupt media the corrupt democratic
party that doesn't care about the
American people we
establishment Republicans never Trump
errs they want to be proven right and
what we describe as the deep state and
tonight you have two of those five
forces working together to malign the
president you elected and we did some
digging today what do we find there's a
lot of reports you've been hearing about
about the inner workings of the mulher
investigation they include a lot of
anonymous sources in fact some of these
reports a totally based on anonymous
sourcing so who are all these anonymous
people feeding all this information to
their friends in the liberal media now
could it be that Muller's team is
actually coordinating with the liberal
media these outlets to turn public
opinion against President Trump that
helps their case now maybe Mulder's
office and their emails maybe they'll
get rated in pre-dawn hours maybe we'll
see that happen now clearly the corrupt
media and Muller knowing there's no
collusion there's no evidence of
collusion if they had it we would know
it by now they're hoping that President
Trump actually fires Muller and without
a doubt like Sarah Sanders said today
the President does have actually the
legal right to fire Muller but we know
if the President does imagine the
political outcry what it would be like
it would be massive in fact this is
likely exactly what many in these five
forces I talked about want because they
believe it would spark all the
humiliating end of the trump presidency
that we the people voted for after all
you know that's been their goal from the
get-go we've always known that and in
their minds this would set president
Trump up to be impeached and the sad
truth tonight is well Muller is on this
witch-hunt fishing expedition it is
abundantly clear that if Trump fires
Muller sadly nothing will go away the
truth is it'll only get worse it'll only
get louder will only become more divided
nothing will get done in the country it
doesn't matter it appears how rogue
Robert motor is doesn't matter what he
did with whitey bulger in Boston and
four innocent people that went to jail
to died in jail but does an FBI
informant in his office that was working
with with Muller and his team oh and
then after two died there was over a
hundred million dollars paid out in that
case it doesn't seem to matter to
anybody in the liberal media that
Muller's pit bull has described by the
new
our times Andrew Weissman that he was
involved in tens of thousands of people
losing their jobs their careers at
Arthur Andersen accounting doesn't
matter at all does it matter
the Supreme Court overturned Weissman
Muller's pit bull nine zero how often
does that happen it doesn't matter that
for Merrill executives went to jail for
a year because of Weissman and that the
Fifth Circuit Court of Appeals overturn
their convictions and it doesn't seem to
matter the courts have excoriated molars
pit bull Weitzman for withholding
exculpatory evidence and it doesn't
matter the Muellers team almost
exclusively donated money to Obama to
Hillary and to the DNC after all why
would Robert Muller hire a guy like
Andrew Weissman with that atrocious
track record why was he ever appointed
the answer is it was a fishing
expedition and it was an effort to get
Trump from the beginning so now we're
stuck with a never ending what seems to
be out of control investigation the
great one Mark Levin he's had and he's
now calling for the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions to be held accountable
without his refusal we wouldn't be here
that's just the fact take a listen I
want to make a point here not intended
to be provocative or controversial and
it will destroy a 30-year friendship
it'll destroy it but I really do think
it's time for the Attorney General to
step aside the buck stops on the
attorney general's desk even if he
recused himself as he did on the Russian
matter this is not the Russian matter I
always save rage for let's see drug
dealers and criminals and you know
organized crime and potential terrorists
apparently not so without a doubt
sessions recusal the appointment of the
now rogue Special Counsel by Deputy
Attorney General Rod Rosenstein is out
of control himself and conflicted out of
this case why he didn't have to recuse
is another question
it just is a clear example of what I've
been warning about a two-tiered justice
system in this country now the
president's longtime personal attorney
Michael Cohen had his home as hotel and
of course his office rated by the FBI
over a hundred and thirty thousand
dollar payment as the personal attorney
and Donald Trump to stormy Daniels and
will peep
not understanding here is when the
special counsel raids the offices of the
president's private attorney Muller is
now basically backdoored his way into
every single Trump business deal at
least since Michael Cohen has worked
with Donald Trump I want to take bets on
what Muller and Weissman are looking for
because I have a pretty good idea
tonight now this is an unprecedented
abuse of power it needs to be countered
and countered immediately the president
should add to his team of top-notch
lawyers a communications team top-notch
communication skills and frankly the
president needs to immediately start
advancing the truth about who Robert
Muller is what his mandate was how far
beyond his mandate is and about his
entire team of Democratic donors and
frankly any negotiations that were going
on with the president talking to Robert
Muller that should probably likely and
if it hasn't already and the president
and his legal team should be preparing
to take this all the way to the United
States Supreme Court that's where we are
tonight it's time to investigate the
investigators as we have been doing we
got to investigate his team of partisan
witch hunters they are trying to
overturn a newly elected president if
you voted for Donald Trump
you better get buckled up because this
is going to be a rough ride and by the
way they should probably remind people
daily that it appears that there's no
longer longer equal application of our
laws in the United States let me give
you a case in point just start with
Hillary Clinton clearly she is guilty
incontrovertible evidence of multiple
felonies mishandling a classified
information destruction of such
obstruction of justice and if you don't
believe me try the leading one day
33,000 subpoenaed emails acid washing
your harddrive with bleach pit
destroying your cell phones with hammers
and was her home raided was a lawyer's
home rated not a chance we have a
two-tier justice system what about fired
FBI director James Comey what about
Bruce and Nellie or what about
anti-trump lovebirds struck in Page what
about lying Susan Rice what about
Christopher Steele the foreign national
that fusion GPS hired and funneled the
money Hillary did through the law firm
and a foreign national about Russian
lies to influence the American people in
an election what about who lied to the
FISA Court judges now you can see on the
side of your screen there really aren't
any anti-trump officials or entities who
have been subject to any of these
aggressive tactics none and we know
Hillary Clinton did commit felonies now
how could the American people have faith
in their justice system tonight and
according to a report from the New York
Times well Muller is investigating
presidents from apparently did a 20
minute speech on skype to the Ukraine
for a hundred and fifty grand from a
Ukrainian national okay good money if
you can make it well guess what well
there's no New York Times report that
that same Ukrainian national gave the
Clintons thirteen million dollars no
outrage no coverage from the New York
Times and talk about hypocrisy well you
won't believe this today the FBI they
actually notified Judicial Watch tom
Fitton is on the show a lot that it's
going to take three long years to turn
over requested communications between
anti-trump FBI agents truck and page
three years can you say two-tiered
justice system now a notorious high
ranking Soviet official II once said
show me the man I'll find you the crime
it sounds familiar to Muller's
never-ending investigation way beyond
his mandate this concept is wholly on
American and it's very dangerous to our
system of justice it's dangerous to the
Constitution if you believe in the rule
of law so tonight I'm saying okay game
on if somebody hits you it's time to
fight back and it needs to come to an
end alright we have to turn our
attention to the media tonight and as
you can imagine the destroyed Trump
media they are salivating they're so
hopeful that they're lying narrative
will be covered up now by stormy Daniels
now with the news regarding Michael
Cohen one particularly unhinged
so-called journalist her name is April
Ryan and literally has taken Trump
hatred to a whole new level listen to
what she asked Sarah Sanders earlier
today at the White House briefing you
won't believe it
with all of this turmoil particularly
that's the president at anytime I
thought about stepping down before or
now no and I think that's a absolutely
ridiculous question we're moving on
Jordan go ahead it's not ridiculous
really April is that what the White
House briefing that's a real appropriate
time to to sort of push your inner
political fantasies here now I'm sure
you're making what you probably your
boss fake news head Jeff Zucker really
proud of you you and your job today now
we're going to bring you more outrageous
examples of the media's hysteria later
in the show but first we are tonight
monitoring this situation that's going
on and ongoing in Syria as a president
now is expected to respond with force to
the recent gas attacks that we know took
place there we've seen the images now
make no mistake President Trump is a man
of his word
and is the United States supposed to
stand by and watch Assad using chemical
weapons on men women and children should
that go unanswered now sadly the same
could not be said for President Obama
when he was on the world stage
remember he drew a line in the sand you
might have forgotten because he did
nothing we have communicated in no
uncertain terms with every player in the
region that that's a red line for us and
that there would be enormous
consequences if we start seeing movement
on the chemical weapons front or the use
of chemical weapons that would that
would change my calculations
significantly and after it's not cross
that red line and continue to gas his
own people remember when the Obama
administration they struck a deal John
Kerry told us a hundred percent of those
chemical weapons were going to be
removed from Syria and then they
declared diplomatic victory you might
remember we were able to find a solution
that actually removed the chemical
weapons that were known from Syria in a
way that the use of force would never
have accomplished Russia has been
constructive in helping to remove 100%
of the declared chemical weapons from
Syria in fact that was an agreement we
made months ago and it never faltered
even during these moments of conflict
people may criticize the sport not have
launched missiles against Assad after
chemical weapons had been used but keep
in mind why we didn't we didn't because
they got rid of the chemical weapons and
that in fact was very important
wishful thinking or willful ignorance
either way even former Secretary of
State under Bill Clinton Madeleine
Albright was calling out Obama's middle
east failure take a look dumb trump says
this is brock obama's fault because the
first time this happened brock obama did
not use military action against Assad's
regime do you think he's right about
that no I don't I mean I do wish Barack
Obama did put down a red line and I
personally wish that we had followed
through on that can America stand by as
innocent men women and children are
being gassed what should happen now of
course I'm not talking about in any way
an invasion of any kind but Assad those
weapons have to be removed when
America's promises are empty and its
leaders a weak and ineffective like
Obama we see what happens chaos death
destruction and the world becomes less
safe we do have some good news tonight
that you probably won't hear about in
the mainstream media yeah Donald Trump
strikes again after weeks of tough talks
and predictions that China's never going
to negotiate on trade yeah the president
of China has now announced his country
plans to significantly lower certain
tariffs on automobiles which is good for
American workers and that they'd be
working towards preserving intellectual
property rights of Americans which is
another good thing two key concerns that
the Trump administration was seeking
good news for American business good
news for our auto industry and earlier
today the president reached out to the
president of China on Twitter he wrote
quote very thankful for the president of
China's kind words on tariffs and
automobile barriers also his
enlightenment on intellectual property
and technology transfers we will make
great progress together and also tonight
the Facebook CEO Mark Zuckerberg when he
was grilled on Capitol Hill today he
faced 44 senators to different
committees we'll have more on that later
in the show